well joe biden
you may recall spent a lot of his time
as vice president meddling in the
internal affairs of ukraine and you may
wonder why ukraine as opposed to say
denmark or senegal or any of the world's
other 195 countries simple because the
ukrainians were paying joe biden's
family a million dollars a year in
exchange for the work that he did and as
president you may have noticed biden has
continued to represent ukrainian
interests most recently in their dispute
with russia biden talks constantly about
all the scary things he'll do if battled
vladimir putin dares to offend the
territorial sovereignty of biden's close
friends the ukrainians
but one thing joe biden will not do he
has assured us repeatedly is send
american troops to ukraine polls show
americans do not want that at all and
biden claims he's heard the message
watch
this would be the largest if he were to
move in with all those forces to be the
largest invasion since world war ii and
it would change the world thank you guys
thanks guys
there's not going to be any
american forces moving into ukraine
they're not going to be any american
forces moving into ukraine that's what
joe biden told us and it's reassuring to
hear that but wait it's not true it's
yet another lie from the mannequin in
case you're still bothering to keep
track of them all fox news has just
learned that there are already more than
300 american troops in yes ukraine now
joe biden's calling them military
advisers just like we did back in
vietnam troops advisors it's really a
distinction without a difference just
last week we were told there are only
150 american troops in ukraine as far as
we know the forces more than doubled in
recent days and that's assuming the new
number is even real and by the way why
would we assume that number is real
these people lie about everything the
truth is we have no idea how many
american troops are in ukraine right now
only that the total is a lot more than
they said it was because again they lie
all the time so here's the question
there are american troops in ukraine
what's going to happen to these troops
if and when the russians invade and the
pentagon says there are no plans to pull
these troops out
and so that means that very soon
american soldiers could be fighting
russian soldiers which sounds to our
civilian ears very much like the
definition of war
with russia
are you ready for war with russia
has anyone asked for your consent or
even your opinion on war with russia
no
that's democracy biden style
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else